the sand and Sun are back the Jordan and
crystal are back and Colton and Tia are
dramatically on track it's time for
roses and Rosie in Paradise we are here
to recap the season premiere of season 5
of bachelor in paradise after a scandal
the show is still alive and I talked to
Chris Harrison about how he thought it
might end but you know luckily it didn't
and that interview is over DT online.com
we have a new site you guys I said for
Paradise we have palm trees palm trees
leaves green things and I have this
really fun margarita glass I am love
Rosie you guys but I also love tequila
just a hint I can't show the friends
because I'm not being sponsored but you
guys this week is always a tough one
because we get a three hour finale part
of it is live from the Bachelorette and
then I got a dive right into two
wonderful hours of a paradise premiere I
need to cleanse this is a charcoal water
and I'm just gonna be cleaning myself
from top to bottom on the inside
starting over just as these folks are in
paradise guys I thought it was a really
fun premiere tell me right off the bat
what did you think of the bachelor in
paradise premiere I felt that last
season after the scandal they were never
really able to get quite back on track
with really good paradise and this
season premiere felt great and I'm
really excited for the season Kendall is
back and Kenny is back I left you kissed
another guy while you're dating someone
else that's cheating and Kevin is back
and Kevin says that Ashley kissed Jared
while they were still dating so that was
a cheating accusation
right off the bat wasn't it oh I asked
Ashley I can Eddie about this if there
was some crossover between Jared and
Kevin when she broke up with Kevin and
got with Jared and she said no but you
can check out the interview a TV online
comments of yourself what you think do
you think that Ashley I cheated on Kevin
with Jared that's what Kevin's saying
I'm crystal crystal is also back
everyone has a kini my Kendall Kenny
Gavin GU his dog and Krystal is looking
sexy on a bike Paris to me is a second
term is crystals voice different I think
so but I asked her about it in 17 cm I'm
calm you guys never she had a voice hey
hey yo yeah I kind of missed it I liked
it
okay so David is back he's the chicken
suit guy from Becca C's and I you
thought of a bunk bed and in these weird
little packages that look a lot like
their shot at people's parents homes we
find out that his mom makes him fruit
salad David I made you some fresh fruit
salad I guess we know one more thing
about him now all I knew before was that
he wore a chicken suit and he started
crap with Jordan oh and he fell out of a
bed I don't know where's this guy's
personality it's unclear to me Jordan is
back and they're still gonna have this
rivalry no thank you I don't need this
just let me watch Jordan talk about
things just good TV I don't need him to
fight with anybody I just need his
commentary I'm a professional model I
definitely will be showcasing the looks
giving them the angles of blonde hair
flowing out big bright smile it's great
it's always nonsensical but sensical
cheers to Jordan
cleansing ourselves of this rivalry I
hope but I don't think we are anyway
Bibiana is here and girl has been
cleansing because she is ready to kill
it with that booty she said my goal here
is to kill them with booty she looks
good baby honest looking good tia is
here and she has a surprising amount of
photos with Colton didn't she Colton
always made it seem like their
relationship was like really casual
maybe just a weekend I guess in 2018 he
can take a lot of photos in one weekend
you know that was interesting it was
just my flashbacks
so Bibiana arrives in Paradise and sees
Chris Harrison wearing blue he's always
sporting that ocean blue and he can
looking great and she makes a joke about
her uterus getting action the road to
get here was a little bumpy yeah
it's the most action my uterus has had
in a while so I am ready for paradise I
don't know what that man here's my that
joke didn't land your uterus getting
action it Jewish appear
there's a different word it starts with
a V but your your two wrists I think
your uterus getting action would just
mean that you're pregnant
anyway the best place to go on a picnic
is like cemeteries so Kendall and Jo
they are talking and you guys do not
drink every time Kendall and Jo have a
weird conversation they're talking about
seeing dead people I think I couldn't
follow I know I lost you a little bit
there no this pairing was unexpected but
did you like it
do you think Kendall and grocery-store
Joe who are so happy to see back on our
screens have a chance it was very
unexpected to me Joe is this like really
low-key like Midwestern like Chicago guy
I did not expect him to be hooking up
with kooky little taxidermist Kendall
from Long Beach there's more to Kendall
than just text her mean ukulele but hey
anything can happen in Paradise venmo
John is here and I'm so glad to see him
again because I did not like when Becca
sent him home that was too soon he's a
sweetheart and he is just such a lovable
little nerdy goober and he says there's
ladies beats and I like it and I'm dead
I'm so glad he's back what a guy were
you glad to see them Oh John again let
me know then we get shirtless Kevin just
a glance that that cleansed me I'm here
for it Kevin are you guys attracted
together that's my big question let me
know
I'm yes Wow I love this because they're
just seeing these bunk beds and
everyone's like wow wow wow this is
amazing
like no you guys have been on bachelor
and bachelorette and a lot of you've
like traveled to really cool locations
and seen hotels like this is really
prettier on the beach but these bunk
beds these bunk beds on the top do not
drink every time Tia says Colton Colton
Colton
Colton Colton I haven't been on a proper
day and so long since Colton that might
literally be the most dangerous game we
have ever played in the history of roses
and roses a you guys how many times did
she say it on this episode if anyone can
give me a count of how many times TSS
Colton on this episode like in the next
24 hours I will send you a present I'm
not joking
[Music]
she gets a date card and she wants
Colton but he's not there so oh my god
tia is already crying because Golden's
not there really because Cole's not
there Tia get it together
but I will say Paradise came to play
this season we got tears within the
first hour to find something real and
serious and lasting Wow
that is intense but here's the thing you
guys don't drink every time this show
gives you a whiplash
whoa because tonight I'm gonna focus on
me and Chris
in the moment well this is paradise and
I gotta check other people out so I'm
gonna go on a date with Chris what I
mean if you really came here for
something serious and lasting with gold
and you get like for for the date card
or something but whiplash hmm a brief
break from the whiplash forum or Kendall
and Joe weirdness Kendall says and I
quote I don't even know if you've had a
conversation about anything yet they're
talking but they're not having a
conversation I'll take it you little
freaking cute weirdos a brief break for
an alle well crystal says that she's not
an aggressor oh my god like I am NOT an
aggressor and she can't process Kendall
and Joe she's upset about that it just
was kind of sad to me because Krystle
has said many times that the environment
of The Bachelor like competing for a guy
is what didn't suit her and then she was
already competing for Joe but luckily
she got herself out of that situation
crystal told me she literally saged her
soul ahead of paradise and that she is
back to her old self before the bachelor
did you guys agree did you see a
different side of Krystal tonight let me
know I feel the muscle oh my god and now
crystals forgotten Joe and whiplash she
and Kevin are already kissing I'll take
it to a hotties with bodies and I'm
saying here for it you guys hair for it
everything was like Colton we just like
talked about that for a second tia is on
her date with Chris and she brings up
cold drink don't drink also we got to
give Chris a little bit of crap here too
don't shrink every time Chris says like
like like I'm gonna be open mind it's
like any girl like that something like
this
I didn't hit that like just like it
generally what's your type
like someone who's not like from like a
fast-paced lifestyle like like 100
percent and I'm like in the same boat
like and I need more now whiplashed he
has gone from wanting serious stuff with
Colton to kissing Chris and whiplash
she says Colton who and I quote Colton
who okay she's over it
but of course whiplash now Colton is
here he has arrived in Paradise just as
Tia was about to be getting over him and
Colton and Chris start talking when he
arrives and I flashed back ahead like
PTSD a flashback to when Colton was
talking to Chris on Beca season ahead of
fantasy suites never that weird
conversation man some of these girls
whose names I pretty much forgot are so
gorgeous Chelsea remember her she's so
pretty
I think this girl's name is Angela she's
really pretty I'll be honest and
remember this other girl's name and this
little trio that's sitting here but man
are these women beautiful who do you
think are the most attractive people in
Paradise this season I want to know tell
me and I'm just one day with her last
night yeah good girl beautiful and so
now it's gonna be like Colton versus
Chris because of course Colton had a
date card and of course Colton takes T
on a date and of course she goes I guess
she's over Chris now whiplash hmm cold
shoulde Vietnam I love when Jordan
comments and tells a story it's just
good TV he starts talking about how this
is Chris's
personal Vietnam his helmets kind of
like lucid it's not strapped in and you
know listen who's
apache just here comes captain america
the seal just coming at this guy
Colton and Tia are on their date and he
says he's got to figure some crap out
and they kiss and then we get the goose
gang finally we get to crush this guy
what was this god these people are just
so here for the drama in Paradise they
are ready to start it they don't care
how much they're acting juvenile or
acting out their own version of West
Side Story the goose gang a group of
guys is gonna confront Colton because
he's not treating Tia right they don't
even know this girl I mean did this seem
insane to you why are these guys all of
a sudden defending Tia not that I'm not
here for men defending women but like
they don't even know her they don't
really know this whole story I'm glad
I'm redeemed and so is paradise
everybody paradise is kicking off and it
is going to be the most episodes the
Paradise has ever aired so please tell
me what did you think of the premiere
did it live up to your expectations
are you excited for the rest of the
season we will be recapping every week
here on roses and Rosie we are going to
give you a new episode every Wednesday
that will cover both Monday and
Tuesday's episodes you guys thank you so
much for watching and of course watch
with us all season long leave your
comments leave your questions reach out
to me let me know and I know who's
already talking about who the next
Bachelor is gonna be I have an interview
with Chris Harrison up where he breaks
down every single possible candidate
it's up editi online.com I have a for
about dinner
mr. Granville when I asked Blake if he'd
ever made the bachelor back on this
one-on-one I'm sorry I did it they had
to do it address the questions they
asked I gotta think about a future and
what's that you did this show never had
I love you so much I'm gonna go sleep
bye